SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much
for coming or listening online.
My name's [? Trinh Tsao ?].
I'm an engineer at Google.
Today, I'm very honored to
introduce my teacher, Chan
Master YongHua.
Born in south Vietnam,
Master YongHua
received a BS from
the University
of Minnesota and an MBA
from University of Chicago.
After working in corporate
management in 1995,
he left the corporate
life to become a monk
and to study with the
Great Chan Xuan Hua.
In 2005, after 10 years
of meditation training
and over three years of solitary
retreat, he became a teacher.
He is currently the
abbot of Lu Mountain
Temple in Southern California.
For the last 11 years, he has
lectured on Mahayana Buddhism,
taught Chan, also
several books, and also
is currently appearing on a
weekly [INAUDIBLE] TV show.
I encountered Chan
and Master YongHua's
teaching 2 and 1/2
years ago after getting
exposed to meditation through
our own Search Inside Yourself
class.
I was looking for ways to
establish a meditation habit
to manage the stress for a
busy life-- for my busy life
as a [? coder ?] and a new mom.
But the breakthrough
did not happen
until I went to a Chan
retreat in Lu Mountain Temple
at a friend's recommendation.
The two-week retreat was a
very transformative experience
for me, and meditating
more than 12 hours a day,
that's more than
I have ever done
before without feeling bored.
And then I went through a few
noticeable stages of progress,
experienced great
peace and relaxation,
and came back feeling
much healthier,
physically and mentally.
Ever since then, I have been
meditating almost every day.
And I see myself
become a better person,
and be more compassionate, less
selfish, healthier, and more
productive at home and at work.
So that's why I believe Chan
is a really powerful meditation
method, and I would like to
bring to Google so that more
people can benefit from it.
Without further
ado, please join me.
Welcome Chan Master YongHua.
[APPLAUSE]
MASTER YONGHUA:
Thank you, Trinh.
That's quite an introduction.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm Master YongHua.
Can call me Master,
just to keep it simple.
This is one of my students,
venerable [INAUDIBLE].
He's been with me how long now?
SPEAKER 3: About five years,
if you count the whole time.
MASTER YONGHUA: The
whole time five years.
So today, we'd like to
give you an introduction
to our form of meditation,
the Chan meditation.
Ours is really kind of
hard core meditation.
The Chan meditation is quite
different from the meditation
that most of you are used to.
Most of you are probably
aware the Hinayana meditation,
which stresses-- the teachers
stress about mindfulness.
You hear the word
mindfulness, usually
it's Hinayana meditation.
Or you hear about practicing
loving kindness, loving
compassion, or maybe Vipassana,
that's Hinayana meditation.
We are more involved than that.
Oh, and by the
way, this is very--
we are very casual, so
feel free to ask questions,
express your opinions.
Chan meditation is quite
different from Tibetan
Buddhism.
Tibetan Buddhism,
by the way, stresses
mantras or tantric practices.
You recite these mantras as
part of the main practice
for the prayers.
We are-- Chan is more
hard core meditation.
So what does it mean
to the practitioners?
Chan meditation has a
wide range of pursuits,
from world pursuits
to transcendental
all the way to enlightenment.
Frankly personally,
I practice Chan
to try to become enlightened.
And so what it means is
that the Chan practitioner
will be given a
better foundation,
be able to build a better
foundation for meditation.
And we have a wide range
of methods of practice.
And therefore our history,
my practice of Chan,
my teaching of Chan
in the last 11 years
or so, we have been able to
help people get faster results,
whether they come
from-- I have students
who came from yoga, from
Hinayana meditation, from Zen.
Master [INAUDIBLE] here was a
Zen practitioner for 10 years.
SPEAKER 3: About 10 years.
MASTER YONGHUA: And
how did we meet?
SPEAKER 3: We met
at a cafeteria,
at a Buddhist cafeteria.
MASTER YONGHUA:
At another temple.
SPEAKER 3: At
another temple, yes.
MASTER YONGHUA: Big temple
in southern California.
I'm sure you've heard
of it, Hsi Lai Temple.
And I was minding my
business eating my lunch,
and he came over and said--
he started talking to me.
I was kind of annoyed,
because when we eat lunch,
we don't talk.
We don't open our mouth, because
we have a precept against that.
We have a rule of comportment
where when we chew,
we don't talk.
So I was rather annoyed,
but he kept on insisting.
And so he said he was on his
way to his teacher's meditation
at temple in the mountain in
a further area, a remote area.
And he said he
was practicing Zen
for-- had been practicing
Zen for 10 years now.
I looked at him and said, how
come you practice meditation
for so long and yet you really
have no concentration power
at all?
SPEAKER 3: The first
thing that he said to me.
MASTER YONGHUA: Chan
language is very direct.
We don't beat around the bush.
And that piqued his
interest, I think.
And he decided to come and
learn more about concentration.
Concentration in
Chan meditation is
we focus on developing
concentration power.
Concentration is measured by
the term called samadhi power
or dhyana.
So Chan meditation
is very precise.
You measure your progress by
your level of concentration.
So the higher the
level concentration,
you will advance you.
This was started-- our style
of practice came from China.
Chan is a Chinese word.
And it was brought to
China by an Indian monk
by the name of Bodhidharma.
He's the first Chinese
patriarch in Mahayana.
And so he founded
the Chinese Chan.
He didn't speak much Chinese.
And yet he was able to teach
meditation to his students.
So Chan is a practice
beyond words.
And it directly
points to the mind.
And if you see the mind,
you see your nature,
you become enlightened.
So the objective of meditation
with our kind of practice
is to really open ourselves.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, would you
mind turning up the volume?
Is that possible?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we can.
But any louder, and
it'll start to feed back.
MASTER YONGHUA: I'll try
to speak up a little.
And then later.
around 8th century
or so, the Japanese
came to China to study
Chan because they
wanted to further their
understanding of Mahayana
teachings.
And they found that the
best way to understand,
to penetrate the deeper
meaning of the teachings,
then you need to
go through Chan.
So the Japanese
monks came to China
and learned Chan for
about three years.
They brought it back to
Japan and called it Zen.
So Zen is like a subset
of Chan, you ask me.
It's hard to really
perfect anything
at all, to really study
well in three years' time.
In our world, PhD takes about
7 to 10 years, let's face it.
And then my late
master, my late teacher
is a Chinese monk by
the name of XuanHua.
Has anyone heard of him?
He's what is called a
patriarch of orthodox Buddhism.
Buddhism is organized around--
Chinese Buddhism is organized
around lineages of patriarchs.
So, for example, the
major lineage of Buddhism
is originated by
Shakyamuni Buddha.
And then he designated first
patriarch, venerable Kasyapa.
And the second
patriarch and my teacher
was the last known
patriarch in Buddhism.
And the distinctive
characteristic
of all these patriarchs is that
they're all Chan patriarchs
as well.
They understand Chan.
They thoroughly understand Chan.
So that's why I learned
my trade from my teacher.
So our temple is a
tiny, tiny temple.
And we quietly go about
practicing our way.
I don't know how
[? Trinh ?] got to us.
And today I brought a few
of my students with me.
And Chan is able to benefit
a wide range of practitioners
from very young to very old.
Some of the students that
you notice in these pictures
is that-- our practice
is kind of more
rigorous than the typical
meditation practice.
You notice, for example,
we sit in Full Lotus.
It's called Full Lotus.
We cross our legs.
And you try to do that,
it hurts like hell.
It's very, very painful
for most people.
These students practice
Chan because-- see
I have some pictures here
of-- that's Anna right there.
She's from Mexico.
We have students from various
ethnicities, Mexican, Korean.
The third picture of
this man right there
is a layperson who practiced
meditation for over 10 years.
And he came to us,
and he learned Chan.
And he got so happy, and
he got so much healthier
that he decided
to become a monk.
Just like a Master [INAUDIBLE]
here, he was a layperson.
And he decided that he
got so much out of Chan,
he wanted to learn
more about it.
And why did you decide
to do it full time?
SPEAKER 3: Well
ultimately, I wanted
to learn the skills to
be able to help others.
I've seen a lot of
different teachers,
and after meeting Master,
I encountered some problems
in my meditation practice.
And then other teachers were
not really able to help me.
I realized Master was able
to help me a lot better,
so that's when I started
following his instructions.
MASTER YONGHUA: We have
also with us Shana.
Shana?
Right there.
Shana came to us
about five years ago.
And she-- and then we have a
young girl right there sitting
in Full Lotus.
That's Tex Beaumont next
to her, the country singer.
He used to be quite
famous in the UK.
And then we have
students from Portugal.
The last picture
at the lower row
is an assistant professor
from the University of Lisbon.
She came and learned
meditation from us as well.
Next slide.
The reason I teach
Chan all these years
is to help people improve.
Improvement, as I
said earlier, is
measured in terms of
concentration power.
You practice meditation in
order to be able to concentrate,
increase concentration.
Next slide, please.
So I give you some examples--
to do some examples of some
of the students.
This couple here
lives in San Diego.
They commute to us
every single weekend.
They'd been bouncing around
from temple to temple.
She's a therapist, has a PhD
in psychology or something
like that.
And she's very
sensitive with energies.
And she came to us and
with her practice--
she had back problems.
And with the practice, she
got better, she got healthier.
And actually, it's
a funny thing.
After about four months or so,
her samadhi power increased.
Her level of concentration
power increased.
And as a result,
she looked younger.
And her husband is Jim.
Jim is a manager, and he
also got a lot out of it,
increase in energy.
And he's a lot calmer
during the day.
Next one, please.
That's Shana right there.
She has her own company.
And she came to me.
What is-- why you
came to us, Shana?
You remember?
SHANA HAN: I was depressed.
MASTER YONGHUA:
She was depressed.
And so she came to
me, and she said,
I want to learn
meditation because I
am hoping that
meditation will help
me fix one big problem my life.
That is I have a problem
getting along with my father,
and it hurts me deeply.
And so I said, yes, Chan
meditation can help you.
And so she believed me.
And I asked her to
get into Full Lotus.
And she doesn't like pain.
OK.
And she was highly
motivated, and therefore she
dealt with the pain.
And she quickly improved.
So after one year,
she asked me, I
want to go back to Korea
to visit my parents.
Haven't seen them
for a few years.
I said, no, it's
too soon for you.
Don't go back.
The second year-- another
year passed, and she said,
can I go back now?
And I said, yes,
you may go back.
You may go back for--
but don't stay with them
for more than two days.
And she came back.
And of course, as
usual, she doesn't
listen to my instructions.
She stayed on the third day.
And she called me and said,
my father is driving me crazy.
I want to kill him or
something like that.
And the third year, that
was around last year,
a couple years ago,
she said, I really
want to go back
and see my parents.
I said, yes, you're ready.
And she came back, and
what happened, Shana?
Could you share it with us?
SHANA HAN: This year?
This visit?
MASTER YONGHUA: Yeah, whatever.
SHANA HAN: Oh, well, I'm
all good with my father now.
[INAUDIBLE] now.
MASTER YONGHUA: So
Shana came back.
And her father, instead of
picking fights with her,
he was eating off her hands.
And so the point
I'm making here is
that if you really have
needs in your life,
and you're willing
to work hard, then
Chan could be helpful to you.
Because we pass
on-- we would like
to pass on that
knowledge to help people,
to help improve your life, to
help you get what you want.
Whatever it is you want,
Chan can be very helpful.
And as a result, what's
so nice about Shana,
I'm very proud of that fact, is
that she got a lot out of Chan.
And she decided to share it.
So she started teaching
Chan on her own.
She spent her own money, her
own time to teach people Chan.
It's not-- do we have
more pictures of her?
And people seem
to appreciate it.
It turns out she has
more students than I do.
I can't figure it out yet.
Next slide, please.
So what is-- how
do we teach Chan?
We're very conservative.
I follow the Chan
training that I picked up
from my late master,
Master XuanHua,
is from the Guiyang
village in Chinese Chan.
There are five major Chan
houses, Chan lineages.
The Guiyang is the
first lineage in Chan.
And to me personally--
I'm probably
biased-- it's probably the
more advanced lineage of Chan.
And later, it
disappeared because it's
so advanced that people
have a hard time following.
In the Chan tradition,
the Chan patriarch,
once they become
enlightened-- you
don't become a patriarch
unless you are enlightened.
And once you become enlightened,
then the responsibility
is to pass on that knowledge
to the next person.
The next person does not
necessarily have to be a monk.
Can be a layperson.
And it happened in our history.
In fact, our fifth patriarch,
fifth Chinese patriarch,
passed on the knowledge of
Chan to the sixth partriach,
very famous.
Sixth patriarch,
very well known.
And he was a
layperson at the time.
So Chan does not discriminate.
We want to pass on the knowledge
to help you get what you want.
So in Chan, there is
personal guidance.
We guide each individual
to become a better person.
And once you become
a better person,
I hope-- the small
contribution of Chan
is that you bring your
knowledge, bring your goodness
and pay it back
to the community.
I'm personally indebted
to this country
and to the generosity
of the people here.
I came here as a foreign student
in December '74 from Vietnam.
In April '75, my
country fell, and I
was able to receive
assistance from this country
to finish my education.
And for that, I'm very grateful.
And I feel that
the spirit of Chan
is the spirit of gratitude.
I'm grateful.
I'm teaching Chan to
express my gratitude
to my teacher, venerable
XuanHua, Master XuanHua
because he gave
Chan to me for free.
Like all his teachers
before, our patriarch
taught Chan for free, just
for the simple purpose
of helping people.
And so he taught me Chan.
And I appreciated it.
That's why I pass on Chan
to whoever wants to learn.
OK.
So in order to learn
Chan, I found out
the last 11 years
of teaching, is
that if you really
have some real needs,
it's much easier
to make progress,
much easier to learn Chan.
So it's a very
personal relationship
in Chan training between the
teacher and the students.
It's not [INAUDIBLE].
You practice meditation, the
increase in concentration
will result in increase
in Qi, the life
force within your body.
Qi is a life force
that circulates
throughout your body, through
energy channels like meridians,
as the acupuncturists
or Taoists call it.
So with this
increase in Qi flow,
you are able to unblock
the energy blockages
throughout your body.
For example, if you
folks use your brains
a lot during the
day-- so what it means
is that you pull up a lot of
your blood to your brains,
where it needs the nutrients
for you to function.
And so what it does is that when
you pull all the blood, meaning
your Qi rises to your head,
then the rest of your body,
the blood is not as strong.
The Qi flow is not as strong.
And therefore, you tend
to develop blockages of Qi
in your body.
So if you meditate-- you
don't need to do Chan.
You can do Zen.
You can do any
form of meditation.
The meditation is a
process where you slow down
your mental processes.
You stop thinking,
in other words.
And when you do that, then you
are no longer making demands
on your Qi in your body.
And therefore, it goes back
to its normal circulation
throughout your body.
And that's why meditation,
any form of meditation,
will help you become healthier
and restore balance, physically
and mentally.
Now what's the
difference in Chan
is that Chan is
specifically-- the way
we teach Chan is to help you
improve your concentration.
Increase in concentration
[INAUDIBLE] increase in Qi.
When the Qi flows more
strongly, more vigorously
throughout your body, it will
unblock the energy blockages
throughout your system.
For example, when you
think excessively,
you will have Qi blockages
up here in your brains.
So after a while, you use
your brain excessively,
your mental processes
excessively, then
at some point in time,
your mind is slower.
You can't think any more.
That's a sign right there that
you have blockages of energy.
That's when you
need-- that's when
it's a good time for you
to stop, take a break,
get up, go get a candy bar, a
cup of coffee, or something.
Take a walk around the campus.
Or even better yet, if you have
some real meditation skills,
all you have to do
is cross your legs
and meditate for a few minutes,
and you restore your balance.
So if you practice
meditation and improve,
increase your
meditation skills, it
means that-- in meditation,
any form of meditation,
it measures meditation
skills by your concentration,
your ability to focus
in a sustained fashion.
And so if you develop the
concentration ability,
the stronger your
concentration, the higher
your level of concentration,
the higher your concentration
power, the higher
level samadhi power.
The higher samadhi
power is associated
with a higher level or Qi
flow throughout your body.
And again, the stronger Qi flow
will unblock energy blockages
throughout your body,
will make you healthier.
Furthermore, let's say that
you go from one samadhi
level to the next samadhi level,
meaning that your Qi flow is
a lot stronger than before,
meaning that-- the Qi flow,
it rises from your navel.
It rises up in this major artery
of Qi, of energy in your body.
It rises up.
As you concen-- as
you start meditating,
this area is called the dan
dian, like your battery.
And the longer you meditate,
your energy builds up here.
As it builds up,
it naturally rises.
It rises, rise, rise,
rises like this.
So it clears up-- first
thing, it clears up
your stomach problems,
issues you might have.
Heart burns?
Very easy.
Cross your legs.
In fact, I met with
a medical researcher
at Cal State Long Beach, and
she said that she researched
on the posture of meditation.
And they found that if
people sit in Full Lotus,
both legs crossed, it increases
their digestive system,
improves the digestive system.
So those of you who have
ulcers-- because people
develop ulcers because
you worry too much.
One very good form
to help restore
your health is to
meditate, will help
your ulcers heal a lot faster.
So first it will heal
your stomach issues.
And then it rises,
keeps on rising,
will heal your lung issues.
Asthma or people who smoke
definitely need to meditate.
Then it rises, helps your
voice, your voice box.
And finally it rises to the
top of your head, the peak.
And what it does is if you
have increase in samadhi power,
this Qi rises.
This Qi is a lot stronger.
It turns out-- and I hope that
someday the medical researchers
will be able to document
that-- it turns out
that with the increase in
samadhi power, or concentration
power, I believe
eventually scientifically,
people will be able to
show that you have more--
how you say that?
The connectors, connections
in your brain matters.
So you open these
channels of energy.
That's why your mind
is faster, and you
are able to see clearer.
Any questions about it?
I know I'm going out a
little bit on a limb.
But hopefully, this is a
hint that I hope that medical
researchers will take a stab
at it and be able to document
the fact that with the people
who have better meditation
skills, actually the brain
should be heavier and should
have more active brain
areas in grey matter.
All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I like measurement.
And I was wondering if you could
say more about how you measure
your ability to concentrate.
MASTER YONGHUA: Absolutely.
That's a good question.
Thank you for the question.
The question is how do you
measure the concentration
power.
The concentration
power is measured
in meditation, any form of
meditation, by samadhi level.
Can we go to the
next slide, please?
The next slide.
OK.
From the Buddhist
teaching-- this is Buddhist.
From Buddhist teaching, we are
living-- we live in our world--
our world consists
of three realms,
if you will, desire realm,
form realm, and formless realm.
Where we live is
called desire realm.
Desire realm is characterized
by a lot of desires.
We want nice cars.
We want a good job.
We want recognition.
We want to be loved.
OK.
All those are desires.
And when our desires
are met, we're happy.
Right?
In this desire realm,
from the Chan perspective,
there is no concentration power.
People who live in the desire
realm are called scattered.
They have zero samadhi level.
So far, so good?
When you learn to
meditate-- a lot of people
I know would meditate
for a long, long time.
They feel good.
They feel happy.
They feel relaxed.
It reduces their stress.
But they cannot go to the next
level of conservation power
called 1st dhyana.
So that's why-- so at the
1st dhyana to 4th dhyana,
you belong to the form realm.
So you transcend.
That's why the non-Buddhist
meditation techniques
that you heard--
something called
transcendental meditation.
Have you?
Transcendental
meditation, all it means
is that you transcend
the realms you're in.
So from our jargon, you
transcend the desire realm.
You move to a higher
realm, like the form realm
or the formless realm.
So what happens when you
move from the desire realm
to the form realm?
You move from zero
concentration, zero samadhi,
to 1st dhyana.
What happens is that you
are able to concentrate
in a more sustained
fashion, longer than before.
All right?
Your Qi level increases.
You have more
energy than before.
You're able to work longer.
For example, when you
go to the 1st dhyana,
you are able to
reduce three desires.
Those people who make it from
zero samadhi to the 1st dhyana
or first samadhi level,
they have less desire
for-- you remember?
SPEAKER 3: Food.
MASTER YONGHUA: For food.
Easier to lose weight.
They have less desire for
what, Master [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER 3: Sleep.
MASTER YONGHUA: Sleep.
And then finally, what else?
SPEAKER 3: Have sex.
MASTER YONGHUA: Who said that?
[LAUGHTER]
Can we share that?
No?
So mentally, your mental
make-up, yes, you still
have desire for food.
Yes, you still want to sleep.
Yes, you still want to have sex.
But it's not as
overpowering as before.
So that's 1st dhyana.
All right?
So as you get to next level, 2nd
dhyana, 3rd dhyana, 4th dhyana,
you're at the peak
of the desire realm--
I'm sorry, the form realm.
Then from the 4th
dhyana to the next level
is called 5th samadhi.
That's why we distinguish
them by dhyana versus samadhi.
Dhyana is still
in the form realm.
Samadhi is in the
formless realm.
So you go from 5th to
6th, then 7th and 8th.
8th is the top of our world.
I'm sure that some
of you know are
aware of-- probably are aware of
the people in the 8th samadhi.
You go to an ashram in
India and see these people
as you walk on these
temples and these ashrams.
And you see these
gentleman who sat there
on the side with the hair
around the head, right?
And then they-- that's
because they are attached
to-- have so few attachments.
So it's a long answer
to your question.
Basically, if you
practice meditation,
the experienced teachers will be
able to guide you and help your
improve zero samadhi to 1st
dhyana to 2nd dhyana and 3rd
dhyana and 4th dhyana and so on.
The reason, for example,
why I told Shana
back there that the first year
you can't go back to your dad
yet-- because she says,
my father whenever
I get into a fight
with him-- I told her--
I'm sure she doesn't remember.
I said if you still hurt
when you fight with him,
then you cannot
control yourself,
and you cannot help him.
So you can't go back yet.
So the second year,
she got to 2nd dhyana.
So she's still talking
to her dad on the phone.
And she says, I can last
for about 15 minutes,
and then I go crazy.
We both yell at each other.
I said, then that's
why you can't go back.
Because if you really want
to connect with your father,
you have to get to the point
where he's used to hurting you.
And if you still
feel hurt by that,
you cannot connect with him.
You lose your composure.
So the third, she
got to 3rd dhyana.
3rd dhyana, she's stronger
than her dad already.
So that's why I told her that
she could go back to Korea
and do as she wished.
And that's what happened.
So what happened
between her and her dad
is that-- I told her,
you know, [INAUDIBLE],
but she didn't believe me.
I said, your dad is--
I admire your dad
because he loves you dearly.
And she said she started
fighting with her dad
since she was six or seven.
I said, you don't
understand him.
Can I finish this or not?
I'll get back to your question.
He's tough on you because
he wants to make sure
that no other man can hurt you.
And after she came back
from Korea in the third year
and dad realized he could
no longer hurt her feelings,
make her feel bad, then he
admitted to her that he doesn't
have to be mean to her anymore.
It was an act.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is all desire bad?
And isn't loss of desire often
associated with depression?
MASTER YONGHUA: Oh, does
it lead to depression?
Where is [INAUDIBLE]?
I have a nun back there
who's sleeping right now.
She's dozing off.
I think we enjoy
your lunch so much.
And thank you for having
such a nice lunch.
She's not depressed.
So the loss of desire, or
your desire not being met
does not necessarily
mean you are depressed.
Depression has a
different reason.
It's a lot more involved than
I have time to go into today.
In short, depression is a lot
more prevalent than you think.
First of all, it
is very contagious.
You remember the expression,
you make me feel so depressed.
You are affected already.
So it's very contagious.
And it's a mental illness that
is, to me, personally even more
dangerous than cancer because
it's a lot more contagious.
You spread it to the
people close to you.
So it's very, very, very--
it spreads like wildfire,
and people are not aware of it.
And there's no real cure for it.
You take Prozac, and you
take all these medications.
All it does is
compresses your mind
so that you can now
go beyond this range.
You don't feel too bad.
You don't feel too good either.
But it doesn't fix
the real problem.
So it really has nothing to
do with-- it doesn't have
much to do with depression.
What's the reason?
Why do you ask about the
loss of desire or a desire
not being met?
Is there a reason for it?
AUDIENCE: I was generally
curious about desire,
because I didn't think that
all desire is a bad thing.
And I'm also curious about
your personal experience.
You mentioned that you'd gone
to University of Minnesota
and then you'd gone
to business school
and lived the corporate life.
And I'm actually curious
about your experience
kind of through these
different realms
and seeing diminished desire.
And I'm curious if you
actually think about life
before becoming a
monk and an abbot,
whether you miss that, whether
you miss having desires, which
is something that I'm sure a
lot of people in this room have.
MASTER YONGHUA: Oh, no.
I still have desires.
We are living in desire realm.
Don't think that you practice
meditation, all of a sudden,
you have no desire.
That's baloney.
As long as we live in desire
realm-- we all are in desire
realm-- we have desires.
I would like to have a red
Ferrari one of these days.
I keep on telling that-- tell
my students that for 11 years.
And they still have not
given me a red Ferrari.
Doesn't mean my
desire's any less.
The desire, as you
practice meditation,
let me put it in the term
that's more relevant to you.
My life is quite
different from yours.
In your practice, you
practice meditation,
and say you go from zero
samadhi to 1st dhyana.
You have less desire, and
your life will change.
And the only means, by the way,
that you have less desire when
you are in 1st dhyana-- when
you're out of 1st dhyana,
you have desires.
Does it make sense?
AUDIENCE: So do you
miss having desires?
Do you miss desiring food, and
do you miss desiring power?
Do you miss desiring sex?
MASTER YONGHUA: No, I don't.
I still enjoy food.
I still enjoy power.
I still enjoy punishing and
giving my students a hard time.
I still enjoy things.
I enjoyed the lunch today.
I enjoy coming here
and meeting with you.
It's fun for me,
because the first time
I'm able to come to a place
where people have the brain
power.
So it's fun to be here.
So it's not what you think.
When it comes to desires,
it's personal choice.
So to be blunt, the
sexual desire or desire
for food or those
desires are good,
are desirable in desire realm.
Once you go into
the higher realms
where you have better
concentration-- with better
concentration, now
you have a choice.
Do I stay in desire realm
and connect with people,
connect with my wife,
connect with my son,
connect with my friends, and go
have a drink, go have a steak.
That's you are in
the desire realm.
You are still there.
You choose to
enjoy those things.
And then you can choose for
a time, when you meditate,
and you say, I'm going to
transcend this and grow
to bring my consciousness
to a higher level.
I'm freeing myself
from all those things.
And what will you get?
You get something
called peace and bliss.
It's a different
form of pleasure.
The pleasure and desire
realm is sensory pleasures,
meaning you enjoy these
flavors, this fragrance,
this sound of sweet words, or
this beautiful classical music.
Those are the pleasures based on
your senses, your sense organs.
When you go into dhyana,
or the higher concentration
level, your higher
level of consciousness,
you will be able to mentally
as well as physically enjoy
a different kind of desire.
It's called peace.
Your mind is more peaceful.
And it feels more blissful.
You feel lighter.
This is a lightness
happening that
is quite different from
the central pleasures.
At the lower levels, the
1st dhyana, the 4th dhyana,
the 5th samadhi to
lower levels, you
won't be able to really
understand the finer subtleties
of this peace and bliss.
But at much higher level,
beyond 8th samadhi--
I teach my students to
reach 9th level samadhi
and higher-- this
peace and bliss
will be so much better,
if you ask me personally,
than sexual pleasures.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
sitting in Full Lotus is very
fundamental to the practice.
MASTER YONGHUA: It's
our secret, yes.
AUDIENCE: May I ask
how you teach students
that have extreme difficulty
or impossibility in sitting
in Full Lotus?
MASTER YONGHUA: The question
is, how do we teach my students
in getting into Full Lotus.
I can't always-- I am
not always able to teach
them to get into Full Lotus.
It's not always the case.
For example, my first
student was in his 70s,
and he was able to sit
with two legs propped up
like two [INAUDIBLE].
And then after a year
or so of practice,
he was able to get
into Half Lotus,
meaning you only
cross one leg over.
And he still cannot get
into the Full Lotus.
But that's beside the point.
Full Lotus is like a
goal, is like an end goal
there, and you go towards it.
So the Full Lotus
is that if you're
able to get into
Full Lotus, then
you're able to make
progress a lot quicker.
If you're not able to,
it's more of a journey,
where you attempt to get there.
And the process of trying to
get there is when you grow.
So we are not
focused on results.
You're focused on
trying to get there.
So, for example, some
of my better students,
even more advanced
than Master v here,
they don't necessarily
sit in Full Lotus.
They sit in Half Lotus.
And they are much higher level.
So each person is
different, because the fact
that-- so Full Lotus is like
an expedient, like a skill.
It means that it sets a goal
out there and to challenge
you to get there.
That's all.
Does it help?
Yeah.
So how do you measure?
Finally, let me close
out with the question
right-- his question.
You measure it by concentration
power, very clear.
Whether you're a
Buddhist or non-Buddhist,
it doesn't matter.
Your concentration power
is expressed, in Buddhism,
in terms of 1st dhyana,
2nd dhyana, 3rd dhyana.
Whether you call this 2nd,
1st dhyana, it doesn't matter.
For example, I met with
non-Buddhist meditation
practitioners, like I told you
about, the Hindus, the gurus,
in the Indian ashrams,
ashrams in India.
They're 8th level samadhi.
It doesn't matter
what you call it.
But we call it
8th level samadhi.
So there are clear gradations
in meditation in terms
of concentration power.
All right?
Any other questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So you've
mentioned how,
through progressing through
these various levels,
it's important to have a
teacher to guide you through.
So I was wondering
is there any way
to pursue Chan meditation
recreationally on our own?
And if so, do you have
any recommendations
on how to go about doing that?
MASTER YONGHUA: Absolutely.
If you are able
to find a teacher,
then you progress a lot quicker.
Because what is the
nature of progress?
You are not
progressing because you
don't know how, you don't
know the importance of making
progress.
Progress is fun.
Progress is productivity.
Progress is creativity.
It's important to you
because what is creativity?
Is it something so
nebulous, so vague,
like only a select few
can have access to?
No such thing.
Creativity is because
you're able to look at it
from a different perspective.
For us, if you
practice meditation
and you increase to the next
level of concentration power,
aren't you looking at it
from a different perspective?
And I submit to you, then,
when you progress in meditation
and your concentration
power increases,
your creativity
will also increase.
Because you now have a
different perspective.
Now your brain has more--
will have more connectivity.
Now in terms of
recreationally, absolutely.
As I said in my earlier
slide, you can go from-- you
can go from worldly pursuits
all the way to enlightenment.
You can practice on your own.
I prepared a book called
"Chan Meditation Handbook."
I highly recommend you read it.
It's in English.
And you can read
it and you follow
that to practice meditation.
And if you have questions,
you can call us.
You can contact us, and we'll be
glad to-- either through email
or phone call-- we'll
be glad to guide you,
to answer your questions.
Now why is it that you
are not making progress?
Because you don't know how.
To go from zero samadhi,
for example, to 1st dhyana,
there are certain
things you can do
to increase your chances
of getting there quicker.
So with the guidance,
this is where--
the Chan training
traditionally is
a teacher-pupil relationship.
So the teacher recognizes
where the student is stuck,
and he or she helps
devise the means to help
the student unstick herself.
Now you can do it with
the help of a teacher,
or you can do it through
the different meditation
techniques, whereby you
are able to free yourself
through the actual mere fact
of practicing meditation.
So in brief, to
answer your question,
I highly recommend you meditate.
All of you should meditate.
Not necessarily
with Chan or Zen,
or doesn't matter
wherever you go.
Just meditate because
it's good for you.
Will restore balance, reduce
stress, improves your health.
And for you who are in
the business of creation,
of breaking new
frontiers, I feel
that you need to-- in order
to be able to consistently do
that, for long
sustained fashion,
you need to improve your
concentration systematically.
You need to improve it.
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]